it was terrifying to have my brother um
Scream and Shout at me and my father say
things that just simply weren't true
Prince Harry opening up like never
before about his exit from the royal
family and the ongoing feud with his
brother Prince William William simply
cannot forgive Harry not just for
leaving but for how he left on Thursday
Volume 2 of the couple's Netflix
docu-series Harry and Megan dropped and
in this episode the pair details their
exit as senior working members of the
British royal family I think Megan was
the Catalyst for a new life for him she
really gave him the confidence and to
say okay there is another way while the
lovebirds have fond memories of their
2018 ideas Harry says the family's
attitude towards Megan changed when her
popularity grew and she started landing
on the cover of newspapers more than
other senior members of the family Harry
says that he and Megan were given their
own Communications team separate from
William and his wife Kate Middleton and
that's when negative headlines and
alleged planted stories started to pop
up
that was heartbreaking ultimately Harry
says they decided to step back from the
royal family after a lot of back and
forth and what they claim were many
leaked conversations they left because
they wanted a different way of life
after spending some time in Canada Harry
and Meg returned to the UK and claimed
they were denied a meeting with Harry's
Grandma Queen Elizabeth II and when
Harry sent a note requesting a meeting
with the senior Royals he says he was
shot down until Megan returned to Canada
to be with their son Archie that's when
Harry says he had a closed door Summit
with his family and things turned sour
it was terrifying to have my brother um
Scream and Shout at me Harry reveals the
current status of his relationship with
his brother who is next in line to the
British royal Throne the saddest part of
it was this wedge created between myself
and my brother so that he's now on the
institution side and I get a part of
that I get I understand right that's
that's his inheritance back in 2020 a
story came out about William bullying
Harry and Megan out of the family at the
time the palace released a joint
statement on behalf of Harry and William
denying the story a statement Harry
claims he'd never even seen and never
approved within four hours they're happy
to lie
to protect my brother
and yet for three years they were never
willing to tell the truth to protect us
and Harry says it was that moment that
solidified their decision to get out of
there it was my decision she never asked
to leave Harry holds a lot of grudges
it's clear he feels that he wasn't heard
that he and Megan weren't listened to
and that they weren't supported now
Harry says he and Meg are moving on and
focused on what's coming next meanwhile
the royal family has yet to speak out
about the docu-series
I've spoken to senior Palisades who said
they are reluctant to comment unless
there is anything damaging
untrue or defamatory in this donkey
series they really don't want to be
drawn into it it's a case of keep calm
and carry on and let's not get too
distracted by this
[Music]